der körper von stacy holz war voller
krebszellen einem multiplen myelom
dieser krebs gilt als unheilbar und
tödlich trotzdem ist sie komplett
geheilt wie funktioniert dieser
medizinische durchbruch jetzt in clixoom
science und fiction
damit hätte stacy er holz wohl nicht
gerechnet sie ist geheilt
als das multiple myelom bei ihr
diagnostiziert worden war seien die
aussichten noch vollkommen anders aus
der krebs hatte selbst auf ihrer stirn
einen tumor gebildet
es war nahezu sicher dass sie an den
krebs sterben würde und dass der krebs
lediglich eingedämmt werden kann für
eine bestimmte zeit an einer heilung war
nicht zu denken
es gibt nämlich nichts was diesen krebs
stoppen kann gab muss jetzt gesagt
werden denn was an der mayo klinik im
amerikanischen rochester gelang ist eine
medizinische sensation den medizinern
ist zum ersten mal die gezielte heilung
dieser krebsart geglückt bislang war
bekannt dass krebspatienten der an einer
virusinfektion erkrankt waren
in einzelfällen spontan vom krebs
befreit wurden aber es gab noch keine
erfolgreiche anwendung in der medizin
das virus infektionen krebs eindämmen
können oder sogar wirklich verschwinden
lassen können das weiß man seit den 70er
jahren schon damals stellten mediziner
fest dass sich tumore nach einer
maserninfektion zurück bildeten
doch es waren 40 jahre forschung nötig
um ein konzept zu entwickeln das
tatsächlich in der lage ist den krebs
zuverlässig zu zerstören
in tierversuchen ist das inzwischen
schon mit einer sehr hohen trefferquote
gelungen das verfahren dass jetzt beißt
ecr holz angewendet wurde war für die
mediziner an der mayo klinik allerdings
erst das allerletzte mittel
hier wurde ein unglaublich starkes
impfserum initiierter serum enthält
milliarden wären genug um 100 millionen
menschen zu impfen und die reaktion von
stacy holzfasern auch dementsprechend
minuten nachdem sie die infusion
bekommen hatte bekam sie hohes fieber
sie musste sich sofort übergeben bekam
starke kopfschmerzen und nach 36 stunden
spürte sie den tumor auf ihrer stirn
zurückgehen
nach einigen wochen war der tumor auf
der stirn und alle anderen tumor im
körper verschwunden
das geheimnis hinter dem erfolg dieser
behandlung die masernviren war nicht nur
so wie bei einer normalen impfung
geschwächt dass sie die krankheit nicht
auslösen können sie waren auch so
verändert
dass sie die tumorzellen gezielt
zerstören
die modifizierten masernviren dringend
in die tumorzellen ein und führen dazu
dass sie verschmelzen und schließlich
platzen
dabei werden weitere viren ausgeschüttet
die durch die modifizierten krebszellen
produziert worden sind es entsteht ein
dominoeffekt der schließlich alle tumore
zerstört mit stacy holz beginnt eine
neue ära der krebsbehandlung auch in
deutschland laufen bereits die ersten
klinischen studien zur behandlung von
verschiedenen krebsarten mit
modifizierten viren
vielleicht ist hier ein weg gefunden
worden wie krebs wirklich sehr schnell
geheilt werden kann
mehr in kriegs und fiction täglich
aktuell in der app die gibt es hier zum
kostenlosen download links wie immer
ohne video beschreibung und über ein
ebenso kostenloses abo freue ich mich
natürlich auch hier geht's zum letzten
video die relativitätstheorie möglichst
einfach erklärt und ich sage wie immer
bis dann bleibt dran